Okay, guys, unemployable peeps, fellow rank and renters, what's going on, guys?
We're going to do a really just super impromptu.
I messaged Stephanie yesterday and I was like, hey, what do you think about going live with
me tomorrow?
And she you're like, well, it depends on what time.
And then I like two hours ago, I'm like, what about in two hours?
And she's like, I have a, you know, she had a closing call or something.
She's like, but I think I can make it work.
So let's do it.
We didn't give anybody a heads up, by the way, here's Porter.
We'll let him in really quick.
We didn't give anybody a heads up.
We've just decided to go live, share her story, do this interview and look at this.
We've got dogs.
We've got babies.
I got to get something on my lap.
Bro, where's your kids at?
Yeah, I know.
So Stephanie, what's your dog's name?
This is Mike.
This is my niece.
This is Gracie girl, Gracie dog.
I like the name of me.
Great.
Ever since I watched the show Armageddon, I always loved the name Grace.
Really?
Grace.
And then we got Ford over here just munching on his hand or his toy.
Just going hard, dude.
I got the bottle.
I got a burp rag.
Just I'm ready to rip, dude.
How old is, how old is Ford now?
He's only, he's four months.
Oh, is, is Ford doing anything productive at the house?
He doing deals yet?
Or is he just like nursing and pooping?
Just sleeping and pooping.
But hey, he did sleep eight hours yesterday.
So get, get this baby, get this baby a whoop watch.
Let's see what kind of REM sleep he's hitting.
Oh, dude.
He slept like a baby.
I had to check his pulse.
I was nervous.
I love it.
Well, Porter, thanks for hopping on Stephanie.
Thanks for being on.
Anybody else that's on, appreciate you.
I know this is super just out of nowhere, but I hope a bunch of people will see this
interview.
So guys, today I want to interview Stephanie, me and Porter want to interview Stephanie
and talk about how to pre-sell your way to $8,600 per month.
Um, Porter is also just so you guys know, just to, to have an idea of why I have him
on here, he's making a, is it 10, 10, six now Porter?
Yeah, 10, six.
I asked you that and making sure you didn't cancel seeing if you got any other deal.
So is that 10, six, uh, $10,600 per month.
Uh, I think a hundred percent of those are also pre-sales.
Yeah.
Okay.
So, um, I wanted to have these two on.
We're going to be interviewing Stephanie though.
But guys, the reason why I wanted to interview Stephanie is I love interviewing
people that I've worked with that I've literally watched start from zero, knowing nothing about
the business.
And then they persevere their way to where they're absolutely crushing it.
They've got momentum on their side.
And, uh, that's exactly what we've got here with Stephanie.
So, um, I looked this up before the interview, Stephanie, you, you started working with me
or you started, I guess, let's just say you started, uh, pre-selling or you started focusing
on the sales piece of this business on May 31st, 2024.
So let's call it June 1st.
So it's been 10 months, nine months, not even, not even that.
Okay.
Something, something like that.
And, uh, the interesting thing about Stephanie, and I'm excited to really get to hear her
story, but she didn't just, you know, sling five deals in the first week.
She, if I remember correctly from the post and from everything else, like there was a
little bit of a learning curve and there was some setbacks and stuff like that.
So, um, is that, is that, am I getting that right?
Or am I confusing this story with somebody else's?
Yeah.
No, you're a hundred percent correct.
I'm not a fronter.
I didn't, I didn't crush it out of the gate.
Yeah.
I was a late bloomer.
So, I mean, I'm, I'm gunning for you Porter now.
Like I'm, I'm crushed.
I'm going to be in five figures and I'm gunning for you, Papa.
But, um, so if you, once you pass Porter, I think there needs to be, you do send me
a message.
We'll, we'll do some kind of a little, uh, some little spit for you because I can't,
and I hope you do a post just roasting Porter.
Hey, I got, I got one cooking Stephanie, this, this week.
Did I for cooking?
I have for cooking.
Oh, yeah.
Stephanie's got for cooking, but you're, you're, I don't know, man.
Um, they're in the air fryer.
They're not in the slow cooker.
Like I'm telling you, like what I love about pre-sell, like I call it like pre-sell is
a microwave.
I'm like screw it, like no, no offense to Chevy and all the organic people out there.
God bless you.
But I am not into like that.
I call that the kimchi, like fermentation method.
I'm like, I don't have, I'm too fricking impatient.
And, and, and because I'll play devil's advocate, I think that a healthy bill, uh, uh, a really
healthy business, you probably have a combination of both.
So, um, maybe what we should do to, cause there might be some people that watch this
that are on later that, um, like what the heck is pre-sell?
What, what are you guys talking about?
I'm sure a lot of people do know what that is, but, um, it, let me have Porter, Porter
explain what we mean.
Cause obviously everybody knows the traditional method.
You pick a city, you pick a niche, you build a website, you start a business, you start
a city, you pick a niche, you build a website, you start doing SEO, it ranks, then you start
worried about selling it.
Porter really quick.
Why don't you just explain in a, in 10 seconds, what, what it is that we do when we talk about
pre-selling.
So basically instead of rank and rent, it's rent, then rank.
So build a one pager, run Google ads, use the leads that we get, sell them to a business
owner.
And then as soon as you collect credit card, go in and build it out.
So you're just, you're flipping the model completely.
Stephanie, anything you want to add to that definition or that description?
No, no.
I mean, I just a hundred percent Porter nailed it.
I mean, it's really, it's just a matter of you're, you're getting the money up front.
So then that you then can backfill it and do all the other fun stuff on the back end.
But you have a business owner who is paying you and then you can just block and load
onto the next one.
You know, what else is cool or what I was thinking about in like, cause I always like to
use an analogy or think about it as like regular real estate, but you know,
um, with, if you were to build apartments, let's say, of course there's people out there
that have a bunch of money.
They go, they, they, they, they've done it for so long.
They know what a good piece of land looks like.
They know the right location.
They know what it should cost per square foot, all that stuff.
They get investors, they put these projects together and then they start selling them.
Right.
But there's also people in like Dubai, for example, where these big companies,
I think it's called the Mac, the mock, these guys go in, they have the plan.
Then they start pre-selling.
They bring you in, they show you their showroom.
They say, Hey, we're going to do this plan for you.
You're actually going to pay for this right now and you're going to help us build it.
We're going to get you a lower rate.
But by the time this thing's built, it's going to be worth $50,000 more.
And you're going to have an apartment or a space in this, this huge complex
that you're going to own.
And so they literally have it self-funded by investors, by people like me and you.
So it's the exact same thing, guys, instead of us going and putting our own money,
our own effort, our own risk, we're literally going and saying, Hey, Mr.
Business Owner, I need you to fund the project that I'm going to own.
And what do you think?
And it sounds crazy if you think about it in like a real estate context,
because in the real estate example, the customer or the business owner would own the property.
But in this example, we own the property, even though they fund it.
So I like that.
I want to jump it.
Like, that was a little bit convoluted for my pea brain because I'm back in the US.
But in terms of real estate, I love that.
Because years ago, you know, I'm down in Vegas.
I know you're up a little north, but they had all these track homes, right?
And so they have phases and they roll them out in phases.
And if you buy in phase one, by the time they're still in phase seven,
they've already increased in price, exactly.
What we're doing is kind of like we're selling out of a trailer.
They haven't even built one yet.
So people are buying off plans, like they don't see it.
And so that developer is taking all those deposits and those sales
and using that money to build out everything.
Or they're building out either that development or they're using it to buy another parcel,
then to chop it up and do the same thing.
So it's OPM.
It's other people's money.
That's a great term.
OPM, other people's money.
The only difference between the examples that we're using and this
is that we're actually owning the property.
Whereas in those examples, the person paying the money would own the property.
We also get to own control and keep the property
that we can then go and sell eventually and all this other stuff.
So super exciting.
The cool part about it, guys, is that if you guys are in this program
and you guys are in Unemployable, you guys are in the right place.
You have the fundamentals down pat.
Shiv is the best in the game when it comes to teaching all things,
SEO, backlinks, content, building a site, ranking a site.
And then what I do is I like to show people how to do it fast.
And so that's what we're going to talk about today.
So let me just share my two goals for this interview.
Number one is I want to inspire and motivate you guys
that if you'll stay the course, that you are in the right place
and you will find success because you're going to see
that didn't happen overnight for either of these two people.
And then I want to at least give you one actionable takeaway
that you can take this week and implement and push it into your business
to move the needle in the right direction.
OK, so here's the reason, Nick, why are you doing this?
Why are you coming to this group?
Well, the reason why, guys, is that I did this exactly like you guys are doing it.
I did the rank, then the rent.
I did it did work.
I got deals, but I could never scale.
I could never get to the numbers I wanted.
Money that excited me was one hundred thousand a month.
And I started doing the projections and it just never made sense
for me to go build out a hundred websites to then try and scale.
And so as soon as I figured out pre-selling, it unlocked
two things that were constraining me.
Number one is time.
Number one, number two is money, right?
Because now I use other people's money, like Stephanie said, OPM.
And I don't have to wait six months for a website to rank.
So I've got some questions I want to ask Stephanie.
And then I'll let you guys ask any questions you have, Porter.
I'm probably going to ask you some, Porter, if you have questions for Stephanie.
But I just want to run through these and we'll keep this nice and tight.
And hopefully there's at least one person that we help on this live.
And then hopefully a bunch of other people will see it.
Okay. So that's not fair.
Cool.
Amazing. Okay.
Okay. Real quick, because I don't know if anyone knows the full story,
but let's just talk before this whole world of digital real estate.
What were you doing for work?
The one year before I started this, I worked for a 501C3, which in the U.S.
That's a nonprofit.
Yep.
I was a salaried employee for $40,000 a year.
And I taught elementary school kids how to grow fruits and vegetables and plant gardens.
Interesting.
I did that for one year because I had just moved back to the United States.
For the 13 years prior to that, I was living in Europe and New Zealand.
And so I was, but right before that, like during COVID and everything, I was in Greece
and I ran for 10 years, I ran a vegan cooking school.
Okay.
It's pretty much like rank and rent.
Yeah.
No, but I've always been in sales.
And so I love planting, I love food, I love landscaping, and I love teaching.
And so I was on my feet.
And then when I came back to the U.S.
And I had to move back to the U.S. because my parents are old
and I had to come back to see them.
Otherwise I would still be in Europe.
So I came.
Hold on.
So where are you at right now?
What city?
Vegas.
Okay.
That's why I thought that.
And I was thinking, and you just really referenced Vegas, but for some reason, anyway.
So, okay.
Good old Vegas.
How's the, by the way, real quick, not to detract, but-
Dude, it's freaking raining today.
It's raining.
Oh, okay. Good.
I'm glad you're suffering as well.
All day.
Like, like, yeah, I was like, where's my raincoat?
Yeah.
Porter, is it snowing in Parowan?
Tonight.
It's supposed to snow a couple inches tonight.
So you guys need it, but keep it over there.
Are you in St. George, Nick?
I'm in St. George, but Porter's like an hour north.
I know.
It's not that far.
Yeah.
It's raining here, but it's going to snow there because it changes a lot.
The temperature of that.
I have all my besties are up.
They all go up.
They're all up at Duck Creek.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
That's going to be cold in Duck Creek for sure.
And if you're up there, you say Duck Creek, not Duck Creek.
Just let's get the record.
Okay.
All right.
Guess what?
I know it's hurricane and not hurricane.
I got it.
You know the area.
So, okay.
So you were doing, right?
A year before, you were working for a nonprofit and now you're doing this.
So in all of your previous years when you were in Europe, did you ever have any sales experience,
tech experience, anything like that?
Okay.
So I have less than no tech experience.
I would tell people, I'm like, I can't even spell IT.
That's actually kind of a funny joke.
Like literally, I had people, I thought about it today.
The last time I used Excel was when I came to UNLV in 1991 for graduate school.
By the way, that was the year I was born and they were really good that year too.
Dude, the running rebel.
Dude, like F Duke, by the way.
Like I bleed red.
I'm a running rebel all through and through.
F Duke.
Yeah.
Anyway, yes.
So no, I can't stand IT.
I always outsourced it.
I have a back, before I had a cooking school, I have a background and I was a recruiter.
I was a headhunter.
I have a background in selling mortgages.
Like I've always been in sales.
So the sales problem was nothing for you, but the tech.
Yeah.
Okay.
This isn't a question I had, but how is selling this different than selling
mortgages or anything else that you've sold?
Well, it's a lot easier.
It's because it's your Costco thing, right?
Because you give them free samples.
Like I can't sample you on a freaking mortgage.
I so agree with that.
Like, you know, like, okay.
So now that, you know, like for those who are like kind of high,
it's a little high level here.
If you don't know what I'm talking about, you know, go look it up.
But, you know, you don't have a lead magnet in mortgages really.
Like, what am I going to do for you?
Like, okay, I can run a free credit report for you.
Yeah.
But I can't let you feel how it is to be in the new house.
I'm not going to do like a little demo closing,
you know, like, you know, signing.
I mean, like, you know, you got to cut.
There's a little bit, there's a little more faith.
You know, you're betting on the come.
So, you know, in terms of the cook, my cooking school, people were like,
I would sell these big giant packages and they're like, you know, like,
I was like, my biggest package was like, you know,
$7,000 to come train with me in Europe.
And so these, I was selling, I taught in English,
even though we were in Spain and Greece, but we taught in English,
because it's an international language.
So I was selling to people from India and Canada and Australia.
So they had to buy their ticket to come stay with me for a month.
And then they had to pay me $7,000.
And then they had to also lock,
put themselves up in a hotel or Airbnb for seven weeks or whatever.
So it was, you know, it was high ticket sales.
And they're like, how do I know you're any good?
I'm like, well, you don't, but they can watch videos.
You know, like, here's an example.
So I could do a little bit of, you know, free sampling,
but you don't know.
But what we're doing right now with the way you do the pre-sales,
we're giving them sample leads.
They're the exact same thing.
It's not like, it's not a scaled down, it's not an abridged version.
It's the exact same thing.
As long as you make sure you give them good leads.
I mean, you don't want to give them scrub leads.
You know, you cherry pick your own leads
and then you send them to the BO.
100%.
From somebody, I sold, of course, a couple of different things,
but selling alarm systems compared to this, I always tell people,
this is like, not that it's easy per se,
because it's obviously takes some work and some skill once you,
but you don't, by the way, just so you know,
you don't need sales experience to do this.
Porter had zero sales experience.
The only thing he ever did in terms of work was worked on the farm.
For me, I sold door to door and selling this,
I sit there and I'm like,
people are complaining about picking up the phone.
I'm like, look, you don't have to knock on a door.
You don't have to go in the sun or under the rain.
You don't have to get the door signed on you,
a gun pulled on you, any of this kind of crazy stuff.
You get to pick up the phone.
And not only do you get to do it from the comfort of your home,
but you get to call and say,
do you want something free that you're already paying for?
I mean, how hard of a sale?
That's the initial sale.
And then you're into the actual sales process.
So Porter, for you on this note,
how difficult was it for you from somebody that had no sales experience
jumping in and trying to do sales?
The first couple were definitely a little bit uncomfortable, I would say.
I think I remember I answered the first one,
or I called the first business owner and I think I totally,
like diarrhea, the mouth, just everything.
He asked me a question, I answered it.
So they definitely go smooth,
but it definitely helps when you have a structure that's laid out for you,
something that you can follow and have a process.
But I mean, it definitely was a lot easier than I had anticipated.
I always tell people the business model is very simple, but it's not easy.
It still requires work.
It's not going to be like this quick, easy cash,
but it's a lot easier in a lot of things.
Okay, let's keep going.
I like what you said.
The first time you do anything, you suck.
I mean, whether it be bake a cake or paint a billboard, whatever you do,
the first time you do anything, it's not your best one.
I mean, the first time, I'm sure Nick, you did a live.
Look at your lives and your content and your courses now versus your very first one.
I mean, whatever it is, your first one is never your best,
but you got to start somewhere.
Yeah, great point.
Really good point.
Okay, so this is a question.
I'm not looking for any specific answer.
I legitimately want to know because I remember for me how it felt,
but from comparing it to when you were at zero,
you're starting this business, you're cutting your teeth,
you're not really sure what you're doing.
I'm going to ask you and then Porter.
Stephanie, you're making 8,600 bucks a month.
Obviously, that's top line, but how does it feel knowing,
hey, this actually works and I can do this and the sky's the limit?
Does that get you excited?
Does that get you overwhelmed?
Does it make you anxious that you should be doing more?
How do you feel knowing, hey, I've made it 8,600 a month, but how do you feel?
I think like you said in a lot of your videos,
you just got to get one already, you're built.
And then even after I did one, I kind of laughed because I watched so many of your videos.
I mean, so many.
I mean, literally, no offense, I kind of got sick of watching you.
I was like, oh, and it got to the point where like,
oh, is it like blonde Nick or is it brown Nick?
Is it bearded Nick or is it not Nick?
I'm like, but I mean, I watched tons and tons of content
and just to really get it dialed in while I was going through your content
and getting going.
And I believed everything you said.
I didn't think you were just blowing smoke,
but you know, and I was like, oh yeah, I want to feel that too.
And even though I did one, I still even, not that I had,
I'm like, okay, I knew I could do it before.
And then after I did it, I knew I could do it.
But then I knew that, okay, now you just go do more.
And again, like my first one wasn't the best.
I now was debriefing or troubleshooting the things I did wrong in the first one.
And you just get better.
You tweak it and you find out what works for you.
So was it overwhelming?
No.
Do I feel like I should be working?
I think every single person in your bit,
what I love about this business is every single person can do their version of it.
Because you do have a lot of people who are doing like, I'm not one of them,
but I know like you asked the other day in the group, you're like,
who's still doing a nine to five and then it's slamming deals on the side.
I'm not doing it.
This is all I do full time.
I knew for me, like this is the bandwidth that I had.
And where I am in my life, I needed to do this full time.
So I just wanted to speed it up.
But that's not right for everybody.
But everybody can do it.
I think the important thing though is for people who are going to do it on the side,
because like, you know, I know you're a blind guy.
People who don't speak English is a first language guy.
You have like, you know, you're a guy with people with kids and this and that.
Can anybody do it?
Absolutely.
Is it more difficult with all those other things on your plate?
Yeah.
But is it undoable?
No.
So it's just a matter of keeping your priorities straight and that's it.
And so all I did was reverse engineered where I wanted to be.
Like when you bring people in, the first thing you have us do,
and once we get into your paid group, is to do our map.
You just got to do your map.
And I call the map the reverse engineer.
It's like, okay, where do you want to be?
Okay, well, if you know where you want to be, then now it's like that's the end.
Like if you put on Google Maps, like that's the end point.
But you know where you are now.
Now you got to reverse engineer it and work backwards and put in all the steps.
Because that's what people get overwhelmed.
Like, I mean, okay, I think most people do, but I mean, I could say I do.
And the way to not get overwhelmed is that old adage, you know,
like how do you eat an elephant one bite at a time?
So you break it down into baby steps and, you know, you check stuff off and you feel good.
And then, you know, just landing your first deal is like checking a big step off.
I mean, it feels really good.
You know, and then you just go to the next one and, you know,
and you just keep on moving, get momentum.
Yeah.
No, I really like that.
I still remember, guys, my very first deal that I remember the first dollar I made online.
And I remember the first pre-sale deal that I did.
It was back in 2020.
I'm not going to tell you guys the whole story.
And by the way, Ford, I'm coming to ask you how you fell in your first deal.
So zip your lip for a second, bud.
No, I'm just kidding.
I'm going to ask him.
Don't worry.
But I remember it was like this idea.
I think we can pre-sell.
I don't know if we can.
And we did a test.
We had a site.
Actually, at this time, I was still building organically first.
I had a site that was generating a couple of leads, ran some ads to it,
did kind of a version of my process that I teach now, but it wasn't perfect.
I got in the closing call and it was the easiest close I ever did.
And I remember getting off holding the credit card digits.
I wasn't even expecting the deal.
I had to write down the credit card or the piece of paper.
And I was like, first of all, I was shocked.
Second of all, I ran the card.
And then all of a sudden, my mind was like just blown.
I'm like, oh my gosh, I could make any amount of money possible
because now I can do this without waiting for it to rank.
It was like, it just clicked.
And I was like, okay, this is the key.
This is that one missing piece that I think the model was missing.
So, Porter, without further ado, since Ford's raised his hand in his own way,
wanting to tell us how did you feel?
How do you feel at 10,600 bucks a month never having run your own business,
never having really worked any other job besides on the farm,
and now you're renting simple websites to local business owners
and basically doing sales to do that without having any experience?
How did that feel?
It honestly gives you a lot of confidence.
It's like knowing that I can still do this while doing something that I love.
So if anything, it's allowed me to be more confident in myself
that I can support a family, myself, go and do and be who I want to be
without having to do a nine to five or work some other job.
You know what I'm saying?
Like it's a weird thing, but it's like a mental thing too.
The money is great.
But what it does to be able to know that you can always make more money
and that the sky's the limit, it makes you want to always do more
because you're around people that are doing so much more than you.
But dude, it's the greatest feeling.
Gives you a ton of confidence.
I've seen the thing I love most is when I see people that start at zero
and then I see them when they made their first deal or 5K, 10K,
is their confidence is night and day.
And that's really fun for me.
So, okay, let's keep going.
Stephanie, was there a moment or time that you almost gave up
or thought about quitting?
Be honest.
And if so, how'd you get through?
I never thought about quitting because I didn't get myself an out.
I assumed that was going to be your answer, by the way.
But I keep going.
I want to hear the rest of it.
But I will tell you, did I scream?
Did I yell?
Did I cry?
Did I have sleepless nights?
Did I want to freaking punch like you and other people?
Absolutely.
The nearest baby.
Believe me, it's not all a bed of roses.
It's like, oh, golf's easy.
All you do is you just hit this ball in this little hole.
I have a friend who's a big...
I know you play golf, Nick.
I have a friend who plays golf.
He never swears.
Never, ever swears.
He's the most mild-mannered guy.
And I'd be like, hey, Mike, how's it going?
I'm like, hey, how was golf today?
And he's like, F golf.
Literally, he was like, golf.
That's the only time he swears is when he talks about golf.
So it's simple, but it's not easy.
How did I get through it?
I literally said...
And it was actually somebody in your group.
I think it was Levi that was helping me, and I was talking to him.
And Levi's one of your students down in Australia.
I was like, Levi, this freaking dude Dylan's just like, volume this.
I'm like, God damn it.
I'm like, man goes this.
I'm like, in some rush, assholes and blah, blah, blah.
I get like, dude, I'm not afraid.
I know I might sound like a sailor.
I'm like, God damn it.
I'm like, what the heck?
And then at the end of the day, he was like, he's like...
It was because he literally said to me, he's like, you know what, Stephanie?
He's like, he said, and I was worried about going into cities
where there were other lead gen people.
And he's like, look, he's like, I'm not afraid of that.
I'm like, really?
Why?
And he said, because I know I can outlive him.
I have the strength and fortitude and acuity and knowledge and everything.
He's like, I'm not afraid of them.
And I went, huh.
I mean, granted, he has years experience than I did.
But I went, oh, okay.
Well, I'm like, well, that makes sense.
And then I can't answer this.
I don't know what happened, Nick, but I swear to you that what happened was
I just had an aha moment.
And I don't know whether it was from one of your videos,
like where you actually said it or whether or not I got the feeling.
I don't know exactly when it happened.
But I had this feeling, this thought, and then I had the feeling.
I'm like, I don't know how I'm going to make this work.
I just know it's going to work.
And that was it.
And then I never deviated from that.
So no matter what, I'm like, okay.
What I did last week and last month, that isn't working.
And I'm like, I make changes a lot.
And I made changes this week and big changes.
And I'll talk to you about them in a little bit if you want.
But I mean, I'm constantly reevaluating and assessing
because all I feel is like when I'm doing things that aren't working, that's data.
And then I'm like, if I'm doing stuff that I know isn't working, then stop it.
Yeah, that's it.
I like that.
Yeah, I don't even have anything to add.
I could say something, but it would be the exact same thing that you said in my own way.
So let's just leave it and move on.
Next question I have, and this is going to be specifically for you, Stephanie,
is why did you decide to start pre-selling
versus just waiting for websites to rank due in the traditional way?
I'm impatient.
I'm not willing to wait.
Again, I think the organic way is a great play.
I think it's super for the right person who's patient
and a person who loves to be sitting behind the computer and loves doing more of the
SEO and the ranking and this and that and wants to just like,
they're the pressure cooker people.
Oh, let me set it and forget it.
No, I want it now.
I want it now.
I want the microwave version.
Air fryer.
I want it now.
I don't have time.
It's like in or out.
I tell people I'm like, this is not rocket science.
We are not building.
I'm not a brain surgeon and you are not a rocket scientist.
I laid it out.
This is what it is.
That's why I don't do any of those.
I call them TOs.
No thinking over.
None of that bizzo.
I'm like, dude, you know it.
You know right now.
I don't hit them this hard.
But I will say this about whoever's watching, by the way,
I want to back up and I do want to share this
because I know I sound like a royal.
I know I come across strong now,
but I will tell you when I on the other side,
when I first saw your videos, Nick,
like I had seen your stuff and when I first
was just learning about the rank and rent industry
because I didn't know about it,
I knew I wanted to work online.
I just didn't know in what venue
because I knew I had to do something that was online
and I really wanted something that had recurring revenue.
And so for a hot minute, I was doing credit card sales,
merchant services, because that has residuals.
I didn't want to do insurance that has residuals.
I didn't want to be a stockbroker.
Like I hate the stock.
I hate the market.
I didn't want to get licensed in series seven, blah, blah, blah.
I didn't want to go that route.
But I wanted to have something where there was recurring revenue.
I don't want to sell high ticket sales
because those are one hit wonders.
I don't want to be like one and then done.
So this really ticked on my boxes.
But when I first looked at your stuff,
I mean, I saw all your stuff
and with your strong personality, I was a little taken back.
And I knew who you were.
I saw you.
I'm like, wow, this kid's intense.
Everybody has their own process.
It took me a while to warm up.
And I'm like, it wasn't until I got in and learned the model.
And then I watched, there's that guy, what's his name?
Like James Dooley, like the guy over in the UK.
Like I was watching all his, do you know him?
Yeah, I don't know him personally, but I've heard the name, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So basically he's like just crushing it in the UK.
Like he's like his own age refs, whatever.
He's like crushing it over there.
But I'm like, you know, and I was like, wow, you know,
like so many people from all different walks of life are killing it.
And I'm like, oh, it all makes sense.
And every single person in my real life,
you know, my family and friends,
when I would tell them about this industry,
they were like, I'm like, A, did you ever hear about it?
No, it's not saturated.
I'm like, but B, I'm like, does that make sense to you?
They're like, yeah, that actually makes a lot of sense.
So then fast forward, then, you know, I just got to the point where
I knew this was no matter what, it was going to work.
I didn't know how.
It's like a combination of the same, you know, it's like squid games.
Like, you know, like you don't know which combination is going to work.
I just knew it was going to work.
I didn't know how long it was going to take.
It was a matter of if, it was a matter of when.
Yeah, yeah, I like that a lot.
For me, in 2020, 2019, I was still doing the business.
I was having mediocre success.
I was still doing it the old fashioned way, the right then rent.
And, but in the back of my mind, it was still,
I was kind of like looking for like,
if there was a better opportunity, I was ready to jump.
You were a lurker.
You were lurking around.
I was a lurker, a dabbler.
I was half pregnant.
Peeping Tom, Peeping Nick, Peeping Nick.
I was, I had the wandering eye, right?
And finally in 2020, I was like, okay, I, you know,
I've got to take care of my family.
I've got to, I'm getting, I thought I'd be a millionaire at 30
and it's, I'm 29 and anyway, I started writing down.
I'm like, okay, I need to make this kind of money.
And I realized I had the right business model, like right inside my, in my hands.
I realized that there was a couple of things that I felt like were broken.
For example, having to wait six months on stuff.
But I knew the model was right.
And I just, I made up my mind and I was like, I'm going to do this mentally.
I'm going to do this until it works.
Like, I don't care if that's 10 years.
I don't care if that's 15 years.
I'm done.
Basically I married the model, done and done.
I was no longer dating and I didn't have any side chicks.
It was like, I married the model.
And as soon as I did that eight months later, I was making a hundred grand a month.
Now it wasn't overnight.
I worked my butt off.
I did the pre-selling.
I made this mistake and that mistake.
But to your point, which I've heard you say a couple of times,
and I want to make sure everyone understands is like, that's it.
As soon as you decide, hey, this is it.
This is what I'm going to make work.
Imagine Stephanie and Porter, if there was either nine to five,
whatever nine to five you wanted.
And then there was this.
There was no drop shipping.
There was no Etsy shop.
There was no FBA.
Do you know how many more people would be successful at this?
Because it would be the only option.
Right?
But the problem-
You want to kick your butt?
Yeah, you want to kick your butt in gear?
Like, like, like anytime.
Like I'm not, look, I'm never going back nine up.
Like, I mean, it's not for me.
But once in a blue moon, I have to get in my car and go travel.
Like, and then I'm stuck in rush hour traffic and I'm like, oh, you know,
like just being stuck in my car, like in that rat race, you know,
whatever you hate about it.
You're like, look, I don't hate Mondays anymore.
You know, like it's been a long time since I hated Mondays.
But I mean, you know, no more hating Mondays,
no more dealing with some boss who's an idiot that knows less than you.
You know, it's like no more times are you going to get told like,
oh, by the way, we're going to have your quarterly review.
Look, by the way, like when I, when I got hired for that job that I was doing,
for that nonprofit, my supervisor that was interviewing me told me six months later.
So six months after I got the job, we were at the Christmas party
and she pulled me aside and she's like, Stephanie, I have something to tell you.
I'm like, what's that Christie?
She's like, when I was interviewing you,
I almost didn't extend you an offer and hire you.
And I'm like, why is that?
She goes, I was afraid of you.
She's like, because I figured like you'd have my job in three months.
And I'm like, well, I didn't want your job.
But yeah, thanks for the compliment.
I was over.
I wasn't qualified.
And I did have to like, I had a downplay because I was,
because I had a headhunting background.
I knew how to like sell myself to get the job, which I did have to downplay.
But from the day I started that job, Nick,
I knew I was either getting fired or I was going to get promoted.
And there was actually one job I wanted,
and it was going to be online and office based.
And they only wanted me in the field.
And I was like, not going to happen.
So I was like, bye.
But yeah, I look like years ago, I used to have this like,
I was doing like, my friends were like, you got to do a blog,
you got to do a blog, you got to do Instagram, you got to do this,
whatever social media, blah, blah, blah.
And I'm like, okay, mine's called be the driver of your own car.
Like, for those, because in my life, there have been times
where like, my sister called me on it, friends have called me out.
They're like, you're just going about your life.
Like, they're like, when are you going to have kids?
I'm like, I don't know when it happens.
They're like, you got to make that decision.
Like, look, I mean, this is years ago.
But I realized I had a, like, it was a shock of reality.
I was literally, my life was occurring and life was happening to me
rather than me grabbing like the steering wheel of my life
and freaking driving my life.
I realized I was in the back seat.
I realized I needed to get in the freaking front seat
and make my own decisions and my own choices.
And that's what this business, you know, allows anybody to do
because you can call your own shots.
You can make as much money or as little money as you want.
You can do it full-time, you can do it part-time.
I mean, look at Ryan Dalton, you know, like, look, he's killing it.
You know, he's still working full-time and he, you know, any, and then he,
and then he ramped up, he developed that whole platform.
And he's like, you know, he's on, he's supercharged and other people are,
you know, I know you have other people who are stay at home moms
who've been in it and they're doing very well.
And then, you know, you have, you have the entire continuum.
There's no wrong way to do this business model except quitting.
Yeah, very, very true.
I want to ask both of you this.
I'll start with Porter and then Stephanie.
But what is one thing and I want you to think about the real answer.
And don't just give me something that comes.
I mean, maybe something comes to your head,
but try to think about the main thing.
But what is the one thing that you can blame on your success?
Porter getting to 10-6, Stephanie getting to 8-6.
Porter, I'll have you go first.
What do you think is the number one thing that you can blame your success on?
And by the way, it's okay to pause because if you've ever seen
some of these guys, Elon Musk, wait to give an answer.
He has a pause that's awkward enough.
You almost think there's a glitch on the YouTube video.
So take your time and Stephanie, if you want to go,
if you have an answer already, you can go first.
Okay.
It goes back to what I was mentioning before.
It's just there is no other option.
There's no fork in the road.
It's not a matter of if, it's just a matter of how.
It's that constant belief.
And I'll tell you, I don't know how I'm going to get there,
but I'm going to freaking get there.
And again, it's like, don't be afraid to try anything.
Whatever you need.
And I'll tell you, I realized that I was, I have, look,
I have some very negative people in my family.
They're my parents.
And so I had to pull back from spending time with them.
And I had to stop and I had to stop talking to people
that don't understand the rank and rent business
because it's very easy for them to go, oh,
you've been in it for six months and you haven't made any money.
Oh, you invested how much money?
Oh, and you went down to New Orleans.
Oh, and you bought how many websites?
Oh, you know, like, I mean,
I can go on and on and on.
I'm like, dude, I don't need more negative Nellies.
I don't need that in my life.
I'm like, dude, check yourself at the door
so that I just zip my mouth.
It's like, I mean, I'm a big proponent.
I'm a huge follower of Dan Martell.
I love Hermosy and I love Dan Martell.
I'm telling you, if you want to follow too,
Nick, your stuff's great.
These are generalists, like Hermosy and Martell.
Fabulous.
It's about mindset and about not getting sucked.
It, you know, Martell actually was tap.
He's a Canadian guy.
And, you know, look him up, if you guys,
if you don't know him, but amazing guy.
And it was X number of years ago, he started making it big.
He wrote a whole bunch of SaaS programs
and this and that started killing it.
Like he was doing stuff in Canada.
And then one day he gets a call
and Richard Brinson wanted him to come to his villa in Switzerland.
And Martell was looking around like, who me?
And next thing you know, Martell goes over to Switzerland
with like nine other guys
and they're hanging out with Sir Richard Branson.
And he's, you know, he's having like all this imposter syndrome,
you know, feeling like he's not worthy of being there.
But he, I think it goes back to playing up
and surrounding yourself with the people.
And Porter, you made a great point about that earlier.
It's about being around other people who are succeeding.
You know, you have to play up in terms of like
being around other guys or women
that are doing better than you are.
And not being around the people who are going to suck you down.
It's very easy when someone is at their job
and they're sour grapes and they hate their life,
it's really easy for them to like poke a hole in what we're doing.
Even if we have a modicum of success
because it's natural human tendency that they have that
it's not that those are bad people.
It's just like, you know, when Britney Spears,
like, you know, like has problems on the news
or Janet Jackson flashes her boob or whatever,
like all of a sudden, like, oh, people love scandal.
People in general want to, like they want to hate on other people
because they don't feel good about themselves.
And so I had to make sure that I kept all that negative stuff out
and I would listen to YouTube videos every night, just audio.
I would stick it underneath my pillow of positive mindset stuff.
And related to money.
So like you guys can YouTube,
but like, I mean, there's YouTube videos for everything,
but it's just audio.
It's, you know, it's not, it's nothing visual.
It's just about, it's really about the positive, the auto suggestion.
And literally whatever you think about will come about.
And if you're worried, it's the, it's the power of,
it's the mindset of abundancy versus the mindset of scarcity.
And I will tell you one last thing.
A year ago, like after I stopped working at that nonprofit,
like I took like six or nine months off and I wasn't making any money.
So like, just for like, just for like kicks and giggles,
I started selling plasma.
And I'd be like in the plasma selling thing,
like they're like looking around, like going like,
like I'd be there in the middle of the day.
And I'm like looking around and you can tell, you just tell these people,
like most of these people don't have jobs.
And I'm like, and all of a sudden I went one day, I'm like, what Stephanie,
I'm like, what the hell are you doing?
Frickin stop selling plasma.
Like you, you got to get out of this like negative,
like you're like a poor broke, you know, person you've sell plasma.
And like, like, could I have used the money?
Yeah, because I was reading my say, like my, you know,
we talk about leaky buckets, you know, like, like my bucket was leaking a lot
because I didn't have anything going in the bucket.
It was leaking because I was investing in this business.
But I said, look, I said, I had to pull the plug.
I'm like, I like, you know, because 50 bucks here, 100 bucks there.
That was great.
But it was conceptually, I needed to stop that negative scarcity mindset
and go full in to be around people like you, Porter and you, Nick,
and everybody else in your group to be like around people
and thinking like, I'm going to crush it.
They're crushing it. There's no reason I can't.
I love that. So yeah, I agree making the decision.
There's no other option. It sounds cliche, but it's a huge thing.
That's burn the bridge, burn the bridge,
burn the ship there, all the different ways of saying it's very, very true.
Porter, what about you?
I would say at the beginning, I think when people would post their deals,
it would kind of make me mad. I would be like, gosh dang,
like this person's landing deals and I've been in this how much longer
or I have more resources. Like it was almost a chip on my shoulder.
And I remember one time I was doing some 10 K coaching.
I remember one guy was like, how is he supposed to, you know, coach me
on if he's not even at 10 K. And so a part of it was just like proving
other people wrong, which is probably the bad way to do it.
But just like, Hey, I'm from a small town. I'm a farmer.
Like I can, I can do just as good as someone that has this much knowledge.
You know, so I think a lot of it has to do with like the chip on my shoulder.
But I also would say just the people that I'm around, like I didn't even
believe that there was that much money to be made until I was in this group.
And I was like, Oh my gosh, like I'm, I'm this little fish in this big world.
And like, why, why shouldn't I work harder? Like if I work harder, I can achieve that.
So that's what kind of drove me.
And that's what it continues to drive me is just seeing other people's success
and like, why not me? Yeah, I love that.
It's true guys. And that's, that's, that's a great thing about this group.
There's some really, really successful people in, and by the way, that's a great,
thanks for your answer, but in this group, not only in, in the rank and rent,
but like one thing I've noticed I really love about this group is everyone's from,
like comes this group already being really successful in the thing that they were doing,
just knowing or realizing at some point that it's not the avenue and the vehicle
they want to use because they want freedom and they want to have, you know,
time freedom, location freedom, financial freedom.
So make sure you guys are, you know, what I, one thing I would say in groups like this,
I have my own groups, I've been in groups, but if you will be somebody that's always looking
to add value and be a producer, not a consumer, not just one of these leeches, not one of these
freaking just try to suck as much information and hide in the shadows, but you're actually out there
if you learn something, you post about it. If you get a win, you post about it. If you get a loss,
you post about it. You're making connections. You're involved running an online business is
very, very lonely at times. And guys, I don't know, five, six years ago, I finally made up my mind.
I started in these groups and I was very scarcity mentality. Like Stephanie was talking about,
I didn't want anybody to know who I was. Didn't want anyone to steal my niches. I didn't want
to be on anyone's radar. And then in 2018, 2019, I started posting, sharing my journey,
sharing my wins, sharing my losses. And guys, from these groups, I've made two business partnerships.
I've made a joint venture. I make over a hundred thousand dollars a year from,
and I've made some really, really good friends. So, but just understand you guys are in a group
of people. It's like we got in the world and we've attracted all the people into this group,
my group, people that want more highly driven people, people that aren't satisfied with just,
you know, their everyday life. So really good point there. All right, guys, let's do this as
we wrap up. I know we've been going for a while here. Does anybody want to spend just a few
minutes? No more than just five, six minutes. If there's any questions, does anybody have any
questions they want to ask Stephanie Porter on the topic of reselling, getting deals, getting to,
you know, but basically a six figure per month or six figure per year
amount, because, you know, 8,600 times up by 12, you're over the hundred thousand Porter,
the same with you. Does anybody have any questions that they want to ask? I'll give just like a
minute. If nobody does, we'll end the stream. And I have one last question I'm going to ask
both of these guys to end. So let me just see before I ask this question, if there is anybody
with any questions. Okay, so I'll keep my eye on this. Let me ask this question.
And then if there's nothing, we'll just end this. So my question for both of you,
let's start with Stephanie. Do you think everybody should pre-sell or is that only
for a certain type of person? And if so, who? I think everybody should pre-sell because
look, even if you do organic, you still have to get on the phone with the business owner.
I mean, there's no reason not to pre-sell. I mean, there's really no reason not to pre-sell.
Hey, you're preaching to the choir. You're preaching to the choir, don't you? You don't
got to convince me. Unless you, you know, you just don't want to help Google or Facebook or,
you know, any of these large companies. But, you know, I mean, there's really no reason not to.
Yeah. There's a look, there's a learning click. For those of you who are like,
there is a learning curve in learning how to run these ads. I mean, it is not, it's not a
bitty cracker cook like cake. Like it's not like this little mic box, you know, this little box
and you pour water and add, you know, like add one egg or whatever. It's not that easy, you know,
but, but, but, but Nick, you know, Nick has people on staff that walk you through it and help you.
And, and then there's some new tools that are available that make it much easier than back in
the stone ages when Nick started this and had to do it all by hand. And, and, you know, so it's
much easier now. And so, and by the way, the one thing I was worried about, not that I didn't want
to tell my story, but when I first started to, went to now, but I think it's real common. People
are worried that, that this industry is saturated because they see new people coming online and this
and that guys, there is so much fricking business out there. It's, it's like ridiculous. Like,
and even in the most like saturated niches, like, I mean, you know, it's, it's, there's so
much business. I mean, it's, it's, and every day new businesses are opening up. And like, I mean,
I shouldn't even say this, but I will. So like, I won't tell you which one it is, but I, I'm running
ads and, and I'm in, I'm in a market and in the same niche that's in one of Nick's trading videos.
I'll let you figure it out, Nick. That just shows like, like that shows, but the point is like that,
that even there, like, I knew there's more room and like, so you, you don't know, you probably
didn't know that because like, there's so much room, like there's so much business, like, I'm sure,
like, I'm sure, you know, you're, you still have your business owner and then like, I found another
business owner and I, you know, and so there's just so much room for opportunity.
Yeah, a hundred percent. Like I've, I, it's funny because as, as I started training this
I, it's funny because as, as I started training this, I started talking about, I've actually
that happened more than once. I'll, I'll be looking at rankings or whatever. I'm like, oh,
there's somebody that's coming in. And by the way, it doesn't make me mad zero. Cause I'm like,
Hey, I can work with a business owner. You can work with a business owner and everybody can win
because as long as we're kicking out all the other guys and then it doesn't matter. So,
okay, Porter, what about you? Do you just, you don't have to, you don't have to agree or disagree,
but do you think everybody should presale? I think so. And I do think that she've always used
this, but like, it's just another tool that you can use. I think the best thing about this is
no matter what you, you go into and you're doing your due diligence, you could look at two options.
You either presale, which it could be your first option. And then if it's too competitive to run
ads, you could organically rank and have those going. So I just love the fact that like you can
be doing both. There's a happy medium to both of these, but like, as far as like personalities
for pre-selling, I think anyone can do that. It doesn't matter where you come from. It's just
if there's a process in place, I mean, like I said, the way that you present it,
you're basically selling it before you're actually selling it. So I think it's a lot more about the
setup than, as you mentioned, the sell. Yeah. I think it's like this guys. I think that even
if you are having a strictly organic strategy, you should have one or two projects. You should
be trying to get one, a deal at all times running some simple ads that can speed it up. There's no
reason. You could have 90% of your strategy being organic, but there's no reason you shouldn't be
running ads and getting deals up front. It's okay. It diversifies your portfolio. Yeah,
a hundred percent. And the other thing I would just really quick mention, and then we'll wrap
this up is I give this strategy, I talk about ads, I talk about, hey, we're going to run ads
up front to a landing page, but you have to understand that you got to pay the piper or
you got to pay somebody that's paid the piper because like, I'll give you this really quick
example. I jumped on the phone with somebody. This is not from this group, by the way,
jumped on the phone with somebody with Kyle about two weeks ago, three weeks ago,
and this person was interested. They're in another group, not this one. They're not having the
success that they want. It's not going fast enough, whatever. They want to run ads, blah, blah, blah.
They don't know how to run ads. And they're like, let me get on. So they get on, they look at what
it's like to work with me and what that looks like as far as a commitment and stuff. And anyway,
long story short, they don't end up coming into the group. And I got a text today from this person
and said, Hey, I just want to say, I appreciate you. You give so much value in your YouTube
videos, blah, blah, blah. I actually feel like I'm in a pretty good spot. I went and bought a
Udemy course on ads. And I think I'm going to be good. And I just took my phone and I was like,
Hey, I don't want this to come across. So I did a voice note. I said, you're trying to do a
shortcut here, bro. If the person that's on the, if the person actually spent a million,
$1.5 million on ads like I did, and they actually know what they're doing, they're going to be
selling a Udemy course for 15 bucks. I'm just telling you that right now. So you could keep
going down the path. I've seen it a hundred times. You can go spin up some ads, waste a couple of
thousand bucks, three months of your life, and we'll have the same conversation, or I can help
you right now. So I say that because I love when people take action. I love when people get going,
but realize that you either have to learn it over the course of four years and a $1.5 million,
or you have to take it and you have to learn it from somebody that's done it. And I promise
you, there's a lot of sharks out there. There's a lot of wolf in sheep's clothing, as they say
in the Bible. And there's a lot of people that I know, and you guys know personally that are
teaching this that aren't making jack shit on their own agency or never have. So the first thing,
if you want to go to any training, I would go ahead and ask them, what have you made? Can you
show me your Stripe account and tax returns? And what are you making right now? Because I promise
you, it's going to eliminate 99.9% of people. Okay. That said, guys, I don't see any-
Well, I want to clarify one thing. I just want to say this. So even though I said that I'm in one
of your own markets, I do want to clarify because it's realized in that market, I'm running Facebook
ads. So I'm swimming in a different pond. And even if you were running Google ads, Stephanie,
I don't- Yeah, but no, but that's the other thing. I just want to show there's so many different ways
you can slice and dice, so many different permutations and everything. Yeah. So I mean,
there's so much business out there. So- Yeah. I have no worries at all. So-
You got to DM me and see if you can guess what market it is.
Okay. I'll DM me and they're like, hey, guess. And I'll shoot a guess. I think I've got a good guess
because I've seen two different ones. So I'll guess.
Really?
Yeah. But maybe they're not both yours, obviously just one of them. But anyway, guys, appreciate
you being on, appreciate Stephanie, appreciate Porter. If you guys do want to learn more about
pre-selling, I have a YouTube channel, which a lot of Stephanie said, I think I have 2.1,000
videos, just YouTube, my name, Nick Wood and RankinRet. We also, I have a free training
if you go to rentsimplesights.com. In fact, Porter, while you're holding the baby, dude,
hold on, freaking Porter. Stephanie, type that in the chat for me, rentsimplesights.com.
You can go see blonde Nick, brown haired Nick. You can go see-
Yeah, no, rentsimplesights, that one is brown haired Nick, don't worry.
And also different lengths too. Sometimes it's short, sometimes it's really long.
The Africa, Nick, you can see.
Yeah, you got everything. You got everything. And then I'm going to drop one more link after
you do that. About three weeks ago, some of you guys know I used to have a free Facebook
group where we would cover any and everything related to pre-selling and this and that and the
rest. And we got to this point where it just kind of got watered down with a bunch of looky-loo
tire kickers. So we actually moved the group over to school. So I'll drop that. It's now called
the RankinRet Academy. I'll drop a link to that. Don't feel like it's anything that you have to
do, but it's just something that you can check out. So there's some links for you guys. It looks
like Kevin said, hey, what's up, Nick, Porter, and Steph, cool. Yeah, by the way, Kevin says,
cool VA. So Ford's the VA now. I love it. Anyway, check out those links. Check out those links.
You know what I forgot to do, Porter? Me and Porter talked about this because he works with
me a little bit. I actually, inside of my group, I actually paid Porter to help out my students
where if they have a question, they can literally jump on a call. So let's do the same thing in
this group. What's your phone number? Let's give them your cell phone number.
So it's 435-393-5694. If you guys have a question, that's Porter's actual cell.
Text Porter, call Porter, preferably text him and he'll be driving a tractor, doing his thing.
And when he has like little 30 minute breaks, he'll jump on phone calls with people and help
them out. So are you cool doing that with people in this group if they want? Yeah, that's totally
cool. You have to message me anytime. Awesome. Are you on Snapchat, Porter? Snapchat, whatever.
You're going to get a lot of tractor Snapchat videos on that. Also, Stephanie, I do want to ask
one last question. What are you going to be at by December 31st? December 31st, what's MRR going to
be at? 56. Okay, let's go. We're going to hold you to that. Okay, guys. Appreciate you being on.
We'll see you next time. Thanks, guys.